みなさん、ここのダガンです。今日
はマット対日本からマットが加わりました。
マットは非常に熟練した日本語を
話し
ます。私のビデオのコメントで、彼
とコラボレーションするかどうかを尋ねられた人がたくさんいます。
または、私
が彼の日本語についてどう思うか、彼の日本語は
壮観です。ちなみに
、この私のボコバのこの名前の要素を歩いてはいけないので
、トミー・リー・キチャンのカダイ日本料理をスケジュールどおりに調理し
ないでください。 彼らはサイキックオーボーイの
トニーホンがこの旅で猫の男ティナをすることができますサイケキノアツリーウォークそれはノソトロスですサルマントニーホンゴハン酸性
タイガーは申し訳ありませんがナカナイトセテラ
ジミー・ティミーは
もっとタフなので、今日は
彼がどのようにして彼の一般的な学習の旅を始めたのかを聞いてみます。彼から
どれだけの情報が得られるか試してみます
。IIはこの質問が
必然的に
誰が日本語が上手かと言う人もいますが、
正直なところ、
マットは私よりも流暢
で、確かに彼の読解
力は私よりも優れていると思いますが、それ
は私に任せます。
日本人は彼の日本語が非常に上手
です。それが私が最初に明らかにしたいことです。
なぜなら
、彼の日本語
は私の日本語よりも優れていると思うので
、それで
始め
ましょう。 もちろん
、1つのことについて1つの発言をすることができれ
ば、視聴者からも多くの質問が寄せられ
ます。
私の見解では、あなたが
本当に高いレベルの流暢さを好むようになると、
すべての個々の話者は
同じような長所と
短所を幅広く持つことになり、それは
ただliを作るのが本当に難しいところまで来ます
比較に近い私は
より良いですあなたは私たち全員が
私たちが得意なすべてのものであることを知っているのであなたはより良いです
言い訳をしているように聞こえたくなかったので、わざとこれについては言及しませんでしたが、YouTubeで行っていることの大部分は
、日本語での創造的な文章の
ようなものであり、明らかにジョークや
すべてのものと同じです。 日本語で
クリエイティブなライティングを始める前は
、ミランの
語彙は今ほど大きくはありませんでしたが、会話は日本語に堪能
でしたが、大きな変化があったと感じました
。 あるレベルに達する
と、その後
は基本的にあらゆる方向へのリターンが減少します。ある
ことに集中すればするほど
、他のことにも影響を与える
ので、
そうですね。 日本語で本当に何をしたいのかが問題になる
ので、あなたの場合のように
、日本語を使って
これらのコメディービデオなどを作る特定の方法があるので
、時間を最適化するのは理にかなっています
その中で最高の結果を得るには、練習などを
してください。上司と超礼儀正しく話すなど、日本語の側面が
ある場合は、
それを訓練するだけではなく
、常に
在庫がある基本的にはそうそうそうそうそう同意
する
ので、私たちを散歩
したり、日本の旅を話してみませ
んか。最初は留学が好きで、うまくいかなかったと思います
が、そうです。 その前に日本語を勉強したかどうかもわかり
ませんええええええええまず最初に私はただ私
がしばらくの間大ファンであったこと
を本当にありがとうと言いたいのであなたが私がこれを持っていることを知っているのはクレイジーです
素晴らしい喜びの人ですが、ええと そうそう
、高校1年生の時に日本語を勉強することに興味を持ったのですが、
オレゴン州ポートランドで
育ちました。シアトルで育ったと思います。
高校1年生の
時、子供の頃に見たようなダブなどではなく、実際の日本語の音声でジェットアニメを見始め
ました。世界最大のアニメファンではありませんでした。
まるで
言語の音に惹かれて、
とてもエレガントで美しく、
すぐに文化にとても興味を持ってくれたので
、もっと学びたいと思った
ので、日本語の勉強方法をググってみました。
ランダムな教科書を読み始め、最初の2年間は日本語のクラスを提供する機敏な高校ができたので
、高校にあった日本語のクラスに転校しました。
ここ
アメリカでは3か月の
夏休みがあるか、学業がないので、私はほとんど夏にそれをやってい
たのです。地元のコミュニティカレッジに通い、
日本語のクラスの2年目を受講しまし
た。 高校2年生の時、日本語
の3年生のクラスに入ることができた
ので、その時点
で、クラスの他の子供
たちは言語の要件があるためにそれを取っているだけ
だったので、私はかなりうまくやっていると感じました。
彼らは勉強していませんでしたが
、私は実際に
勉強していたので、クラスでとても上手くやっているのを知っていて
、それは私を生意気にさせました
が、それから私はいつも日本語
のウェブサイトと
これを見ている人は少なくとも
名前は聞いていると思いますが、基本的にはケニア出身
の佐本を捕まえ
てイギリスの中学・高校のように港に行ったのですが、とにかく雨に来ました
大学のリカと彼は、21歳のとき
に日本語がゼロ
でアジア言語のバックグラウンドがないことから始めて、日本語が
まったくない状態から流暢に話せるようになり
、就職の面接に合格し、ソニーに採用されたと述べました。
18か月後、これは
すべてアメリカの大学に
通い、クラスを通過することを想定し
ていて、パートタイムの仕事など
をしていたので
、mp3を使用していることを知っているメディアを通じてインターネットに完全に没頭することで彼は主張しました 選手
で、大学時代は日本人の友達に囲まれているだけで、
日本語をすぐに流暢に話せなかった
ので、彼のブログを読ん
ですぐにクリックして、
基本的に
そこにいると言っていたのは理にかなっています。
私たちの社会には、子供と同じように大人
として言語を学ぶことは不可能であるという共通の信念があり
ますが
、この信念はちょっとしたファラに基づいて
います cyなぜなら、
このような信念が人々にどのようにもたらさ
れるかというと、彼らは
あなたが教科書やクラスを知っていることを使って言語を学ぼうとし
、それを数年間行っても、実際には結果が得られないからです。
私は言語を学ぶのが苦手だ
と思うか、私は
大人なのでもう言語を学ぶことができないと思い
ますが、実際には、
その大人がしていることは
、子供が実際にしていることとは完全に異なっ
ていました または、乳児
が最初の言語を習得しているときに実際に行って
いるのは、乳児が
24時間年中無休で
言語に完全に囲まれて何万時間も聞いているの
に対し、クラスを受講している人は
おそらく週に2、3時間程度
です 言語への露出はごくわずかで
、
文法方程式の学習など、まったく異なる活動
を行って
いるので、大人が
実際に n幼児の場合
、幼児と同じ結果が得られ
ます。最終的には、現時点ではこれが当てはまらないと
思います。
第二言語習得と
第一言語習得の間にはかなり根本的な違いがあると思いますが、
作業の前提として
このアイデアを取り入れただけで、日本語やええと
たくさんの時間を過ごすことができ
、また
、Oh Tokiも使用している
ので、SRSの使用を勧めているので、ki
と 私はホンキーを使ってたくさん
の新しい語彙やそのようなことを
学ぶだけでなく
、言語にたくさん触れることができたので、長期的
にはかなりうまくいくようになりました
が、基本的にこれ
は 私の人生、より
具体的には、私が
高校の3年生のとき、私が2年生の3年生
から卒業したとき、それは私
がすべての日本語を常に実行することに真剣に取り組んだときでした。
これからは
日本の映画しか見ませんでした
テレビ番組を見たり、日本の本を読んだり、
日本人と一緒
に遊んだりしました。
彼のプロセスを再現する必要が
あり、少し逸脱するリスクを冒したくなかった
ので、私が望んでいた結果が得られないことを知っているので、正しいIIは本当に
壁のボスにボールを行きました、そしてそれは
おそらく心理的に非常に健康でした
必ずしもそうすることを勧めるわけではありません
が、私はそれを6か月間
行い、その6か月で大きな進歩を遂げましたが
、6か月で日本人を
得ることができるのは限界があることを知っています。
当時、日本に留学したのは
半年近くだった
ので、留学中はずっと日本語の半年で2年間の伝統的な学習をしなければなり
ませんでしたが、これは私の学校ではありませんでした。
アニメで何度も見たことのある日本の高校生の体験を本当にしたかったので、オンラインで見つけたのはこのプログラムだけだった
ので、
留学プログラムを見つけ
て申し込み、彼らは私をグマ県に送ってくれまし
た。 日本人に、なぜグマイソンに行ったのかと言うと、必ずしも日本で最も興味深い県ではありません。
それが私
が行った唯一のことです。
ええ、
でも私は業界のレースだったので
、それを最大限に活用することができませんでした。基本的に
、彼らが
送ってくれた学校は
、学生を一流の大学に入学させることに非常に焦点を当てた
学校でした。
非常に高レベルのクラスは非常に厳格
で多くの学生を必要としたので
、彼らは
勉強に多くの時間を
費やした非常に真面目な学生でした。
mと
私は、彼ら
が毎年アメリカからの外国人留学生を迎える
理由は、その学校が
英語に特に重点を置いて
おり、プレフィクスチャで最高の英語スコアのいくつ
かを持っているからだと思います。
よく覚えていません
が、GU GU matul Cole Cole Cole Cole Coleとは呼ばれていなかったと思います。
私が働いていたとき、私はそこに
行ったと思い
ます。 でもそうとにかく、最初は
みんなとても親切で、
私に会えてとても興奮していました。なぜなら、彼らは同じ年齢の外国人はもちろんのこと
、外国人と実際に交流した
ことはなかったからです。 どんなに時間と労力を費やし
ても、6
か月では
会話に影響を与えるには十分ではないので、その時点で日本語は非常に上手
です。
特に英語の高校生は、スラングがたくさん
含まれています。  ke
彼らが私に話しかけるとき、彼らが
意図的にゆっくりとはっきりと話すとき、私は本当に
何を
することが
できました
か？
英語を話すのは、
テストやTOEICなどの勉強をしているのと同じように、英語を話す
ことができなかったので、まったく話せなかっ
たので、私は本当に孤立してしまいました。
本当の友達を作って、
ホストブラザーは私にとても親切でした。私
はホストファミリーと一緒に滞在していたので
、昼食時に彼と彼の友達の隣に座らせてくれ
ました。 彼らが何を言っているのかわからないので、私
は基本的に一人でそこに座っていた
ので、本当に
孤立
しているように見えました。
私が持っていたのでちょうど私のせい ホストファミリーと一緒に日本
に出かけるのではなく、週末に18か月で日本語を完璧にし
たいと思ったので、家にい
てアンキのフラッシュカードを作り
、一日中居眠りをしたいと言いました。 これは
本当に悪い決断でした。もし私が戻ることができたら、私は
日本語を少し脇に置いて、日本語が上手になるために人生を
休まないことを知って留学経験を楽しんだだろうとは思いませんでした。
でも、10代の頃は
とても近視眼的で、私の唯一の
目標は、mm-hmを始めてから18か月間、日本語を流暢に話せるようになりたいということでした。
私のホストファミリーは
ちょっと待っているようなものだったので、私たちは
あなたのために食事を作ってあなたを学校に連れて行っている
ので、あなたは一人であなたの部屋に
座って私たちを無視するのが好きです
読めなかったみたいでした
そのムッシューは私が言っているように大丈夫そうそうそう
彼らは私に家の周りをもっと手伝って欲しいと思っていたと思うが私はそれを
理解しなかったそして彼らは実際
に私にそれを直接言わなかった
うーん
、とにかく、
私は日本にいる間、日本語をたくさん
勉強し続けて
いたので、日本語をたくさん進歩させました。
本当に落ち込んで
悲惨
だったので、やがて早く帰国して10ヶ月の留学になるはずだったのですが
、6ヶ月で帰宅できて、
その時点でどう
したらいいのかわからなかったです。 日本で最高の
経験ですが、私は一年間日本語を勉強してきましたが
、それはとても進歩しました
が、私はまだそこにいないので、
これを最後まで見たいと思い
、勉強を続けたいと思いました。
私がアメリカにいる間、私は非常に激しく
日本にいたときは単位が取れなかったので、コミュニティカレッジに行って高校を卒業したので
、実際の高校に戻ったら
、かなり遅れていたはずで、それ
はちょっと
楽しいことではなかったので、続けました
その時点から勉強するために非常に入力に焦点を合わせていたので、私
は
毎日何時間も日本語を聞いて読んでいて、本に
出てくる言葉のためにホンキーなフラッシュカードを作っ
て
いました。 ずっと日本語を始めてから3年くらいだっ
たので、
帰国して2年くらい
は
日本語がよくわかり、小説が読めなくなったと思い
ます。 ほぼ
問題なく、映画なども問題なく見ることができました
が、まだ日本語はあまり話せませんでした
が
、その少し後に、通うコミュニティカレッジ
から4年制大学に転校しました。
4年制大学のマイクのコミュニティ私が行ったの
は日本人の交換留学生がたくさんいるので、
そうですね
、私の大学の外に日本人のコミュニティ
が
ありました。 私
はそのコミュニティに滑り込み
、彼らと友達になり
、日本人と付き合い、
実際に日本語を話し始めることができ
たので、その時点ではほとんど99％の
入力1％の出力でしたが、私は非常に強力な基盤を持っていたためです
そして、
話し始めると
すぐに、私の脳は
すべてのパターンを何度も見たので
、私が正しいと思っていたすべての種類の受動的な知識を活性化するのに少しの練習しか必要なかったので、私は非常にすぐに流暢になり始めました そして、
そうそう、私はさらに2年間
その学校に通い、
本当にハードコアな日本語を勉強し続けました。
そして、私が約5年
になるまでに、私はどことほぼ同じレベルになりました
。 私は今、この
3年間
、YouTubeチャンネルを運営して、
他の人が日本語などを学ぶのを手伝ったり、ちょっとした改善をしたり
していることを知っています
が、今では
ほぼ毎日日本語で過ごしています
が、 英語などで多くの時間を過ごして
いる
ので、必ずしも上達しているわけではありませんが、特にそのほとんどが日本国外であったことを
考えると、5年間でかなり良いレベルに達したと思います。
おもしろいここで、あなたが言ったこと
を反映したいくつかのこと
を言います。また、IIは最初にこれについて言及したとは思いません
が、
マットはまた
、彼のチャンネルで私にインタビューするビデオを挿入し
ます。 だからこのビデオは私の
チャンネルに行き、別のビデオは彼の
チャンネルに行き、それから私たちのパトレオンの両方に行く3番目のチャンネルがありますが、
忘れる前に言いたいのですが、いくつかのことを
私も経験したとおっしゃっていましたが
、チャンネルの前で少し話しました
が、13歳の頃から
自分の部屋で一人で日本の勉強を始め
ました。 武道
やアニメのように、そして日本のすべてのもの
と
同じように、私はそれについて何かがとても面白いと思った
ので、IIはそれを
約1年またはおそらく1年半の間行いました私は
基本的にこの小さな離陸を終えました
日本のオックスフォードシリーズとII
では、1冊の本でかなり進歩したように感じましたが
、両親は
私が高校で受けていたスペイン語のクラスの受講をやめたくなかった
ので、あなたができるようになりました
」
高校で日本語の授業があったのに、日本語を勉強していました
ので、日本語に興味を持ち続け
、日本の音楽をたくさん聴いて、
日本のTのように見える国際的なテレビチャンネルのように見ました。  Vは
週に1回4時間くらい
見ているのでいつも見ていましたが、
テレビのようなベックス
のようなラジオのようなものもありましたが、当時はテレビの
オンラインだったので、基本的に
はそれも見続けました
日本語などはあまり勉強していなかった
ので、その一年間勉強して
、かなり長い間日本語に没頭していましたが、大学2年生から
積極的に勉強を始めました。
その
主な理由は
もともとビジネスに行って
いたので、ビジネスクラスを始めてすぐに嫌いだったので
、これは自分には向い
ていなかったので、日本語を勉強するの
がとても楽しかったと実感しました。
日本語を勉強すると同時に
、言語学全般の授業を受けました。
申し訳ありませんが
、
この言語学の授業中に、
教授がそのようなことを言ったときに、このカメラを見ていたはずです。
それは私に固執しました、そしてそれ
は書き込みシステムを持たない世界に何千もの言語があるということ
です、そしてそれでこの種の
私は言語を別の方法で考えさせました
言語は本当にそれが
話されている要素なので、私
は何よりも話すことに焦点を当て始めようとし
ます、そしてあなたは
これにも簡単に触れましたが
、第一言語の
習得と第二言語の
習得には違いがあるようで、私の教授は話しました
これについても少し説明します。
最初の数回の
レッスンの後、彼は言語学のさまざまな部分について話し始めました。
社会言語学の形態
や音声学、音声学など
、私にとってはまったく新しいものの
ようでした。
言語の音の研究と彼
はあなたがトーンと中国語を知っているようなことについて話していました
そして
英語とドイツ語のようなアクセントを強調しますそして私はスパンだと思います
また、
スカンジナビアの一部の言語や
日本語では、高低アクセントがあり、人生で
これまで高低アクセントという用語を聞いたことがない人がいない
ようでした。 対立するメッセージ
のように、
日本語の発音は
とても簡単だと言わ
れていましたが、日本語のコースでは話し合われていなかった日本語の別の側面
があったので
、図書館に「私は思う」という本がありました。 日本語の
音声学作者が誰なのか思い出せない最初の数回のレッスンのよう
に音声学のビデオを入れたのはこの一人の作者だと思ってい
ましたが、別の本であることが判明したため
、正確な作者を思い出せません。
その本の正確な名前ですが、それは
日本の音声学に関する良い本で
あり、あなたが知っているような
、高低アクセントや高低アクセント、すべての
給料やパターン、そしてすべてのtのこのまったく異なる世界に私の目を開いたのです。
母音の削除と母音の詩は
、私が聞いたことのない多くのことを語っています。
私の
先生は、第一
言語習得は第二言語習得とは異なることが多いと言っていたので、
私は同じようなことを経験しました。 この教室で日本語を学ぶことは私にとって生産的であり、私
が
聞く日本人の大部分は他の外国人が
日本語を話すので、私はクラスを続け
ていますが、
すぐに留学
プログラムに申し込み、その間ずっとそれを手に入れまし
た そして、
留学している間ずっと、自分自身を制限しようとしました。
できるだけ少ないクラスを受講し
、できるだけ
多くのネイティブスピーカーとたむろ
するように
しました。 日本の映画を
繰り返し聴いたり、
オーディオブックやそのようなものを聴いたりするのが好きで、II
は話すという点で
確かに自分のmを感じたことがわかりました yの発音は
、クラスメートの多くよりもはるかに速く改善されて
いましたが、彼らは間違いなく
文法や
エコロジーなどで進歩を遂げてい
ました。私たちが取ったさまざまなアプローチを知っているのは親切でした
が
、後で私はおそらく作ることができると思いました それは
後でええ、ウンキの
ようなもので、基本的
には後でそれをするのが最善ですが
、あなたが言ったように、私は早い段階でネイティブスピーチで自分自身を囲むことに集中しているような気がします。
私の部屋で
は、外国人ではなくネイティブの日本語で日本語を学ぼうとし
ています。私たちは外国人ではなく、アメリカ人が
日本語を学ぼうとしてい
ます。それは私にとってかなり大きなことだったと思います。
あなたがより良くなることができるネイティブ入力
ええええ完全にそれ
は私がいつも私のチャンネルで言う最大のことのようです
mm-うーんそして音声学について好きです
彼らが聞いているとあなたは
言う 話は高低
アクセントのことです。
高低アクセントについて言われなかったのと同じよう
に、実際には
高低アクセントを気にする必要はなく
、十分な日本語を聞けば自然に拾うと具体的に言われました。 私
は、IIが高低アクセントをまったく調べなかったと本当に信じて
いました。私は、日本語を学ぶのに約4年かかりました。それは
、私がすでに
1年間大学に通っていたときであり、4年と言うと
、最初のアクセントすら数えていません。  2つは
、iCard leeが数えた後の時間と比べると、頭の
中でそれほど重要ではないクラスをやっていたところですが、4年間
日本語を集中的に学習して
いたとき、実際にはかなり良いと感じました。
おかしなことに
、先週のようなビデオを投稿したところ、実際よりも
タイヤが優れている人たちをからかうような楽しみがありました。
横浜モーターソングエゴピンクゴースト
エンジンエゴデー
イーグルザハマスのマスカヨニの家 静かに
、コンガIIでのカーターとオーのゲーム
はそこにありますええええ基本的
に彼らは彼らの仲間よりも良くなっているダニングクルーガー効果に陥っている人々は彼らが
言語でもう少し快適になり始めましたそして だから
彼らは本当に生意気になり、彼らはまだどこまで行かなければならないのかわからない
ので、私は
おそらく
自分自身をかなり自由に表現できるのと同じような顔をしてい
ました
私の学校では日本語が勉強しているので、とても生意気で
、男のように思っ
ていたので、この日本語のことはほとんど理解していませんでした。
日本人の友達に聞いたので
、たとえば電話で日本語を聞いたら、
私が外国人だったのかわからないの
ですが、
私がネイティブスピーカーではなかったと言うことが
できますか？
当時IIが驚いたのはおかしいのです
が、それから私は彼に
、私のスピーチがそれを与えるのは何でした
かと尋ねまし
た。日本人は学校で
高低アクセントについて何も教えられていない
ので、彼らは皆イントネーションを言いました。 アニメ彼ら
は高低アクセントとイントネーションの違いを知らないので、
それをすべてイントネーションと呼んでいますうーん、それでしばらくの間
、彼らが何を話しているの
かわかりませんでした
。 声明などの右側のピッチを上げる
ので
、間違っていた場合は、どう
やって修正するのかということです
が、それは非常に曖昧なことだ
とわかっていますが、最終的には、彼らが
高低アクセントのアクチュについて話していることに気付きました。 味方
面白いことは、
私が高低アクセントの道を歩み始めたの
は、このDieGTを自分の携帯電話にアプリとして持っていた
ことです。私は
DJDeanです。
高低アクセントがどこにあるかを知らせる数字の形で、私は
これらの数字を永遠に見ていまし
た。彼らが何を意味するのかわかりませんでした。彼は
それらを無視しているだけです。数字をクリックすると、
このページに移動します。
さまざまなピッチグラフをすべて
表示します。ある日誤ってクリックしたところ
、心が吹き飛ばされました。これは、ずっとそこにあったようなもので
、私はこれに完全に
気づかなかったのです。そう、
その時点で 私はこれ
が私の日本語の何が問題なのか、私は
これを完全に見逃し
ているよう
でした、そして私はそれについて私ができるすべてを学ぶようにそれをすべて勉強し始めました、そして特に私が
古いアッカパターンのように学んだとき私
は 私は
これを正しく理解
しているわけではありませんええええいつもそのパターンの問題だけで
ええ確かにトリッキーなので
その時点でIIはpH
アクセントの研究を始めました私はピッチアクセントを知覚するために自分自身を訓練し始め
ました 私の認識の一部ではないので、
そう
です、自分自身を買いだめし
ているので、間違いがあっても完璧に聞こえる
ので、ピッチアクセント
に何が起こっているのかを知るために自分自身を訓練し始め
なければなりませんでした。
聞くの
は比較的簡単で、
すぐに最も一般的な単語
のアクセントパターンが何であるかを理解し始めた
ので
、それを聞くことができず
、数か月の間に私は
私が本当にこれに気づいたところ
まで来て、
それが同じようなことを経験した日本のええのそのような巨大な特徴である前に、私がこれを聞いていなかったようなものになり始めました。
高低アクセントに気づき、勉強を始めたのですが、
留学中に通ってい
た日本の大学に転校する直前
に、自分で勉強を
始めました。
それについては
、日本人の教授をいじめて、
この日本語のような音声学のコースを作成するように
したのですが、それはまだカメラ大学で行っているようなものの最初のようなものでしたが、
いつものようにいつもの
ように尋ねたようでした 新しい
単語私は
高低アクセントとは何かの
ようでした そして、
彼らはノーノーノーノーそれは視力の
目標であり、私はノーノーのようでした。それは私が視力の目標と言ったものでし
た。 正しい方法
私は
この男よりも一生懸命日本語を勉強
したので、彼らは素晴らしかっ
たです。 本当にこの
ことを真剣に受け止め
なければ
なりません。そのような瞬間、言語習得では、恥ずかしい思いをしたり、
怒ったり
することがよくあります。そのようなことを本当に覚えているときは、その記憶があります。
知っ
ていると、それは
私がちょっと爆弾のパターンを聞くことができるようになった正確な時間でした
が、英語で存在するアクセントのパターンのように、
本質的にどこかで常に事故があり、
あなたが触れた1つのこと 簡単に言え
ば、あなたは日本語で自分の間違いを聞くことができなかったということです。私は
この本当の本当のことをすぐに拡張したい
と思います。私はこの理論を持っています。おそらく
かなり正確だと思います。 発音の
スケールが1から10の場合は
、高低アクセントを含む一般的な発音を
、自分が
いるレベルより上の人の間違いを聞くことができないと言っ
てみましょう。
5歳のとき、6歳の
人は完璧な日本語を持っていると思います。なぜなら
、彼らが犯している間違いを聞くことができないからです。
さらに同じ考えで、私は
基本的に
、流暢な錯覚と呼ばれるこの概念を持ってい
ます。これは、言語をまったく話さず、
他の人が話すのを聞いた場合
、彼らがそうであるかどうかわからないというものです。
彼らは完全にゴミになる可能性があり
ますが、あなたにとっては完全に流暢に聞こえます。
なぜなら、あなたはそれをまったく知ら
ないので、
あなたが知っているポリグロットのように
、彼らが自己紹介をするこれらのビデオを作るということがあります
18ラ 日本語か何か、そして初心者には
本当に印象的ですが
、実際にはそれらは
本当にひどいように聞こえるかもしれませんが
、それらの言語のいくつかでは理解できないかもしれません
が、あなたはただ言うことができないので、それはまったく同じで
あることを思い出す必要があります
コンセプト
ですが、ゼロになっていると、ゼロを超えると
まったく判断
できず、何が起こっているのか
まったくわかりません。正確には、
プライマリの1つであり、プライマリの1つでした。
私
が最近のビデオを自分のように自主的な
日本人の専門家として作った動機は
、私の日本語
の発音が
1から10のスケールで、おそらく8ポイント5の間で、
9.5未満の低さのようにまだ残っていると思うからです。
確かに
私の日本語には確かに私が拾うことができる
ものがあるので、それは間違いなく何かですが
、ネイティブが拾うことができる他のもの
は私が拾うことができない
ので これがあります
日本語がとても簡単だという誤解はありません
レベル6や
7のような人がたくさんいて、彼らは日本人だと思って
いますこれは遠いときは完璧です
から、私は告発の
ように言いたくないと言っていた
ので、コメディーを通してそれをやろうとしました。
基本的には
、私たち全員がもう少し勉強して、
少し良くなることができるように、その点を強調しようとし
ました。 ですから、腕を骨折しないでください。背中をよく試してみてください。
この問題が日本人にとって特に悪い理由の1つだと思います。この理由は
、日本人
はほんの少しの日本語
能力であなたをほめたたえるでしょう。 ゴルゴ動物園全体
よりもチャンネル内でミームになり
ます
が、基本的な自己紹介ができれば、
日本語の日本語のようになります。
これが初めての人のために。 ビデオ
またはこのチャンネルへt でも、
そうそう、あなたの日本語は本当に
上手ですよね。もしあなたが本当に上手
なら、彼らはあなたの日本語が完璧だと言うでしょう。あなたは日本人
よりも上手です。
日本人
は、
電話で話し
たら、文字通り100％日本人のように日本人
だと思いますが、近くにいなくても真実では
ないので、丁寧であると誓います。 ああ、そうじゃなかったように理解できるようになるまで、しばらく時間がかかります。
実際には
、あなたが本当にそれ
を一粒の塩で服用しなけれ
ばならないという意味ではありません。
日本語でこういう言葉
が出てきますが、何なのか思い出せませんが
、謙虚なパイを一口食べます。
正しい言い方だと思い
ますが、似たような経験でした。
私の話している日本語は完璧だという印象を受けました。
これを教えてくれた日本人は私の友達だったので、
YouTubeにビデオを投稿
したいと思います。見知らぬ人を方程式に取り入れて
、日本語がどのように完璧かについて話していると
すぐ
に、誰かが
見知らぬ人が実際にノーと言っているので、私
は今、
自分の日本語が完璧ではないことを知っていると言っても恥ずかしくないところにいます
が、私
は
同時に、私は完全に日本語
を話す非ネイティブの日本人スピーカーを本当に知りませ
ん
。つまり、あなたがネイティブの英語スピーカーであると仮定するような逆の状況を考えると、あなた
はあなたの中で誰かに会ったことがありますか？
大人として英語を学び、
実際
には英語圏の国で生まれ育ったように聞こえる人生
つまり
、多言語のルカのように本当に良い人は
、彼の英語がいくつ
かの点で驚異的です。  m  y英語
ですが、それでも彼の母国語で
はないことを知らせる残骸がまだ少ない
と言うことができます
。だから、私はあなたに知られたくないので、それが不可能だと言うつもりはあり
ません。 確かにあなたは決して知ら
ないので、多分それは可能かもしれませんが、それは
非常に困難であり、それ
は目標としては非現実的だと思いますが、私の
考え方は常により良くなるために
努力することです
私がやる最後のポイント
あなたは知ってい
ますmm-うーんええええええ私はそれに完全に同意しますそしてそれは私のパトレオンシリーズであなたが知っている私のチャンネルで人々にいつもやるように勧めていることの1つは
彼ら自身が日本語を話すことを録音することです
その理由のひとつは、
振り返る
ことができるからです。過去に何度も何度もありましたが、
今は大丈夫でした。今は日本語が上手くなり、
完璧に
なり、1年待つようになります。 戻って見てください
あのビデオで思っていたの
ですが、
あのビデオでは、正解
ではなかったのに気づかなかったことが聞こえるので
、日本語を話していると、日本語に何かがあることがわかります。 聞き取れませんが
、勉強を続ければ、将来はもう少し聞き取れるようになる
ので、日本語の上達に取り組む
のはいつでもいいという考えに
賛成ですし、そうだと思います。 完全にネイティブなレベル
に到達することはおそらく不可能であり
、非常に若い年齢から両方の言語を話す完全なバイリンガル環境で育った人だけが
その完璧な発音を達成できることを知っています
が、同時に多く
の人はそれをしません 完璧になれたら勉強するだけ
だと思うのは特に健康的だとは思いませ
んねええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ AJシットを読んだら
彼は、彼が電話としてのネイティブと混同され、電話でのネイティブと混同される時点にいることをあなたが知っていると主張します。それは
現実的
です。それを達成しない場合、あなたはチャンプです。
それは基本的に彼が言ったことであり、
これをティーンエイジャーとして内面化
することは、私が自分の日本語についてどのように感じたかに実際に否定的な結果をもたらしました
。
どういうわけか失敗ええ、私
は長い間私の日本語について本当に気分が悪かったのですが、
その期待は完全に
非現実的で
あることに気付くまでは
ええええええええ私はそれに同意します
確かに、私のような人が
、私のレベルが
8から9の間にある場合は、申し訳ありませんが
、日本語が完璧ではないのに、ネイティブとして合格する場所であるにもかかわらず、音がしたことがあります。
味方が
断続的で、
誰かと
電話で数分間話している場合や、以前に何十回も会話をしていることを知っている場合などです
が、
本当にあなたのように感じます
誰かがネイティブの
種類ではなく、話す時間が長くなり
、会話が難しくなることを
理解してください。そうすれば、私たちが良いニコルのようなものを与えているのか、そういうものを与えているのかを知っているネイティブとして渡すことができます。
しかし、言語はgqoだけではないので
、この特定のビデオの実際のことを覚えておいて
ください。終了する前に、他
に話したいことがあります。
間違いなく制限時間を超えてしまうような気がし
ますが
、高低アクセントと音声学について結論を
出すのは
、音声学を勉強することと実際に
意識することの組み合わせだということです。 それについての知識と
本物への大量の露出の
組み合わせで最高の結果が得られると思います。
どちら
か一方しかない場合は、露出しかない場合
は多くの露出が得られ
ます。  -うーん
、勉強するだけでは、実際にそれを知覚するように自分自身を訓練
する必要があるので、おそらくそれほど良い音にはならないでしょう
が、両方を持って
いるときは、
ちょうど良い音に最も近いと思います
確かに聞こえるかもしれませんが、私は
その感情に同意します。私が説教する重要なことの1つは、
基本的
にすべての日本人が常に同じ考えで
あるということです。
ウェブサイトや私のパトレオンですが
、これらのレッスンを単独で見ているだけでは役に立たないので、
常に日本語で自分を取り巻く
必要があります。 レッスンからの知識が
あるので、私はいつも
人々にこれらのレッスンが良いことを奨励しようとしてい
ますが、シリーズを最大限に活用したい場合は、できるだけ日本語で自分を取り巻く必要があります
私がいるということは、
私たちがこのことについて一日中話し続けることができると確信していることを意味し
ますええ、おそらく私たちはもう少しフィードバックを得たらおそらく先生をするでしょう
が、今の
ところそれはおそらくカットするのに良い場所なので
私たちは このインタビューに参加してくれたMattvsJapanのMattにもう一度感謝し
ます。その後
、彼が私にインタビューしたときにインタビューを撮影し
ます。ご覧になりたい場合は、以下のリンクを残してください。ご覧いただきありがとうございます。
そして、私は
あなたたち全員とまたすぐに話します